[Music]
what's new from Hollywood and the likes
about your favorite movies and series
well quite a bit the creators of
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
talked about an alternative ending a new
image from Star Wars Ahsoka raises a lot
of questions and Dwayne The Rock Johnson
is getting his own Fast and Furious
movie plus there are changes to Captain
America 4 and updates on Zack Snyder's
new movie Rebel Moon last but certainly
not least Wednesday season 2 is expected
to get way more intense stay tuned for
the details
Star Wars fans are currently eagerly
awaiting the new Ahsoka series The Cult
figure is one of the most popular
characters in the franchise and the
first trailer also made massive waves
some time ago a new image now raises big
questions because some things don't
quite add up the so-called inquisitors
are feared former Jedi who hunted down
the remaining Jedi after order 66. we
could already see them doing their
Sinister work in the series Rebels
Obi-Wan Kenobi and the video game Jedi
fall in order one of their distinctive
features are their red lightsabers in an
exclusive image from Empire magazine for
the Ahsoka series we now see precisely
that kind of saber wielded by a person
in dark armor there's just one issue
Ahsoka actually takes place like the
Mandalorian after episode 6. so after
the downfall of the Empire and various
stories have shown that the inquisitors
should have been long gone by then what
exactly this is all about will hopefully
be answered in detail in the new Star
Wars series either way the new images
make us want to see more Rosario Dawson
was already convincing in the role of
Ahsoka Tano with her performances in the
Mandalorian and the Book of Boba Fett we
can't wait to see the appearance of
grand Admiral thrawn and where the
series will rank in terms of quality
among the many Star Wars series Ahsoka
will be released on Disney Plus on
August 23 2023.
Rebel Moon Zack Snyder's latest project
will be coming to Netflix later this
year this week there are several pieces
of news including new images and
information about the release because
according to the director it will not
stop at one movie The Story plans for
Rebel Moon look ambitious so far
somewhere in the almost infinitely large
Universe exists a moon on which a
peaceful Colony lives the focus is on
the warrior Korra who wants to protect
the moon from the encroachments of the
ruthless Tyrant balisarius at all costs
she therefore wants to solicit for
support in the whole galaxy and gather
the very best Warriors for this purpose
you can get a first impression from
newly released images that show most of
the cast around leading actress Sophia
Botella director and co-writer Zach
Snyder also revealed a few new details
about the movie it was originally
planned as a three-hour single film but
was then split into two shorter ones the
explanation is that movies do
particularly well on Netflix when they
run under two hours and Snyder's Vision
cannot be limited to one shorter film in
addition Snyder announced that he is
planning two cut versions of Rebel Moon
including a longer director's cut this
one is probably more intended for adults
and as we know since Justice League the
Snyder cut is sometimes even better than
the original we are looking forward to
more information and can't wait for the
streaming release of Rebel Moon which is
scheduled for December 22nd 2023 on
Netflix should the movie be well
received by fans it's likely that Snyder
will create an entire film Universe
around Rubble moon in the coming years
in less than a year Marvel's Captain
America 4 will hit leaders Marvel
Studios now came forward on social media
and not only presented a new image but
also announced that the adventure gets a
new name meaning the previous title
Captain America New World Order will be
replaced the new official title is
therefore Captain America Brave New
World currently we can only speculate
about the reasons for the renaming both
titles are also well-known terms outside
the movie series while New World Order
is repeatedly used in conspiracy
theories Brave New World is the name of
a famous dystopian novel by Aldous
Huxley either way both names suggest a
plot that will probably involve nothing
less than the complete reshaping of
society if only the captain didn't have
a little say in the matter since the
events of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier the hero has been played by
Anthony Mackey the succeeding Chris
Evans a new image from the Captain
America 4 set now shows Maggie together
with Harrison Ford who takes over the
role of Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross from
the late William Hurt Ross meanwhile is
the president of the United States Liv
Tyler and Tim Blake Nelson are also part
of the cast reprising the roles of Betty
Ross and Samuel Stearns from The
Incredible Hulk the movie is directed by
Julius Ona who previously worked on the
Cloverfield Paradox for example the
screenplay was penned by Malcolm
Spellman who was also in charge of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Captain
America 4 Brave New World will hit
theaters on May 3rd 2024.
it recently became known that various
spin-off projects for the Fast and
Furious franchise are in development and
now we got the first details one of the
biggest stars of the series is not only
coming back but is also getting a
standalone film we're talking about
Dwayne Johnson Alias Luke Hobbs after
months of back and forth we finally
learned that he is back for Fast and
Furious 11 and things keep moving as the
rap could exclusively bring to life
Universal is developing an entire film
around Johnson's character the movie is
to link the current part of the fast
series with its sequel thus it is
explicitly not a continuation of the old
spin-off Fast and Furious Hobbs and Shaw
from 2019 even if the same screenwriter
Chris Morgan is involved the rock also
announced the movie with big words on
Twitter he had settled the dispute with
Vin Diesel last summer and he added that
he was overwhelmed by the positive
response to fast X and that the audience
always comes first for him there is no
release date for The Fast and Furious
Luke Hobbs Solo movie yet but if it is
to hit theaters before Fast and Furious
11 production should get started soon we
will keep you up to date as always
at the age of 20 Jenna Ortega can
already point to a remarkable
filmography after her feature film debut
in 2013 in Iron Man 3 she appeared
mostly in horror flicks such as
Insidious 2 Scream 5 and scream 6. this
week however Ortega spoke less about her
movie appearances but more about
Wednesday season 2 which is said to be a
lot creepier than before according to
her overall Wednesday is the most
successful Netflix series ever after
squid game and stranger things so it's
not surprising that those responsible
are eagerly awaiting the next season in
which Wednesday's story will continue to
unfold in season one we get our first
glimpse of Wednesday's life at Nevermore
Academy the teenager had to bring her
everyday problems including romantic
relationships in line with her
supernatural abilities in the podcast
armchair expert she reached revealed
that the time of romantic love stories
will fade into the background and
instead they will fill this Gap with
more daring horror elements Ortega will
also have more say in the second season
whereas she has so far only been the
leading actress the 20 year old is now
also attempting to work as a producer
and is thus taking on significantly more
responsibility she had previously shown
the motivation to have more say in
shaping the script which ultimately got
her into trouble with some of those in
charge including director Tim Burton we
are excited to see how the new horror
elements in season 2 will be perceived
by the fans and look forward to the
series release on Netflix which is
expected in 2024.
Spider-Man across the spider-verse is
making more than just animation fans
hearts beat faster in theaters right now
the sequel to into the spider-verse is
thrilling audiences around the world but
now there is information regarding the
ending of the movie which will certainly
disappoint some fans first of all this
news contains spoilers about across the
spider-verse so if you haven't seen the
movie yet head to the cinema enjoy one
of the highlights of 2023 and then come
back to this news alright are you ready
so here are the details on what should
have happened at the end of the new
Spider-Man movie as Indie wire learned
from talking to producer Phil Lord
there's a good reason why across the
spider-verse doesn't have a post-credits
scene nothing really fit that could have
happened after the actual conclusion of
the film there was even a pretty
elaborate plan already and a cut scene
of the movie spot hangs out in a villain
bar and can't get a drink because
everyone is ignoring them he eventually
steals a drink but it just flows back
out of his holes as he drinks the scene
was meant to emphasize that among the
bad guys spot is a loser in the intended
post-credits scene spot returns to the
same bar but this time he is the center
of attention proudly sitting in the best
seat and all the other villains are
subordinate to him Alan Hawking the head
of character animation love this idea a
guy everyone makes fun of returns and is
now the boss but unfortunately this
final scene only works if there's also
the first scene and that didn't make it
into the movie that's why Spider-Man
across the spider-verse has to do
without a post-credit scene this does
not harm the success of the movie about
Miles Morales and the other spider
people however the film has already had
the second most successful opening in
cinemas in 2023 and has received
excellent reviews this obviously wets
the appetite for more third part
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse will
be released on March 29 2024 and other
projects such as Spider Woman Spider-Man
4 and a Miles Morales live-action
Spider-Man movie are also in the works
want to know more about what you can
expect in the future then take a look at
our new series preview about Daredevil
born again where we talk about all the
important aspects surrounding the Marvel
series that is set for release in 2024
and should there be any news that didn't
make it to our video that get you
excited this week make sure to share it
with the others in the comments thanks a
lot for watching and see you next week
for more kenocheck news
[Music]
thank you